hi I'm Christy coha and I am an artist
and founder of Christy covet studio
[Applause]
today I'm gonna give you a tour of the
green room that I designed with the team
here at Kelly Clarkson show they reached
out to me and they had these ideas they
wanted to incorporate the art and we
couldn't stop talking we had so many
thoughts we wanted to do so we're like
let's just do a total takeover and make
it just this magical happy place so I'm
gonna walk you through so we've got some
proofs from my proof collection here
which are created from my original
artwork and then over here you're gonna
see the start to this wall mural that I
designed specifically for the green room
and this comes from my chromatic harmony
series I wanted to create something that
just had a lot of color and energy and
movement to me color is like the notes
in a song and the way you put the
combinations together really evoke a
cool feeling over here you've got one of
my favorite new pieces my radiate love
and as you can kind of see like as we
were picking pieces they work together
they're so different but you've got the
radiating lines that contrast with the
stripes of the wallpaper and they just
radiates love and so does everybody
around here so it just seemed like the
perfect piece for the space and then
we've got pillows a rug with my vibrant
striped pattern is right here
so over here we've got my colorful world
agate piece and it's hand embellished
with crystals and glitter which it just
makes the work so much more interactive
when you move around the piece and the
light hits it it it sparkles like water
and sunlight I think there's so much
beauty all around us and you know if we
open our eyes we can really really
appreciate this this is my bloom
wallpaper and this is created from
original artwork it's from Michael
is that I like to do I start by doing
collages and incorporate personal
photography illustrations found objects
magazine clippings and I collage them
all together over on this wall it
extends and kind of completes the whole
room so lots of color lots of fun and we
just wanted everyone to have a great
time while they were in here we need to
be on the show thank you so much I
really hope that you enjoyed the tour
and hopefully it gave you a jolt of
color and happy for your day I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this